hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
thanks so much for being with us the
phony democracy Defenders that's the
focus of tonight's
angle all right just as they scrambled
to stop the rising Trump campaign back
in 2015 they're back in strafing mode
again making wild and scary predictions
Trump is promising to resort to an
authoritarian tactic should he become
president again if you don't think he is
dying to silence his critics in the
media think again his top priority if he
becomes president again is Vengeance
Donald Trump uses Nazi terminology to
dehumanize his opponents now the
headlines are so bad they're actually
funny from The New York Times today why
a second Trump presidency may be more
radical than his first well he has long
exhibited authoritarian impulses blah
blah blah you get it now over the
weekend Trump responded in a speech in
Iowa cleverly turning the table on Biden
over the past few years you've watched
Biden and his band of marxists communist
fascists try to Crush free speech censor
their critics criminalize descent
destroy attorney client privilege and
even attempt to imprison their leading
electoral rival by far on bogus charges
that happens to be me in case you forget
happens to
be we love you but somehow I'm not
worried
I'm not worried that's why we're doing
this because we have to straighten out
our country of course the New York Times
poo pooed president Trump's attacks
saying Mr Trump's accusations against Mr
Biden which he referenced repeatedly
throughout his speech veered toward the
conspiratorial he claimed the president
and his allies were seeking to control
American speech their behavior on social
media and their purchases of cars and
dishwashers okay I was reading that
going how is any of that untrue it's
totally true now it's good to see that
Trump was pushing back on that charge
that American populism is somehow going
to lead to some sort of dictatorships
ridiculous they cite Trump's plan to
take power away from unelected
bureaucrats by turning a larger portion
of the federal Workforce into Political
appointments as a real problem
apparently their argument goes like this
by giving the president more power over
the federal
bureaucracy we would be marching toward
a
dictatorship but think about this for a
minute
in the first place it's nice to see that
the media finally admits that unelected
bureaucrats wield a significant amount
of power just as we've always claimed
but now let's have a serious
conversation about whether that's
appropriate Biden's supporters want to
make sure that those bureaucrats are not
chosen by the president or any elected
official they want a system whereby the
bureaucracy hires its own members and
promotions come from within now remember
all that power held by unelected
bureaucrat bureaucrats is wielded as the
bureaucrats themselves want not as the
voters want welcome to the
administrative State now of course the
Press would tell you that bureaucrats
are proud civil servants they're
trustworthy because they are chosen by a
neutral process and they're supposed to
act in accordance with the law but no
one not a single person knows anything
about how Washington Works believes that
our bureaucracy is
neutral everyone understands that the
bureaucracy is just another branch of
the democratic party now for as long as
I can remember it's always been socially
Progressive like the Democrat Party it's
always had a weakness for China like the
Democrat Party it's very friendly to
plutocrats who donate to the right
politicians and like the Democratic
party it despises Middle America who it
sees as fundamentally
evil now ask yourself this at the
department of HHS health health and
Human Services are they going to promote
pr- lifers within the federal
bureaucracy at the Department of
Education are they going to promote
people who believe in
homeschooling at the Department of
Treasury are they going to promote
people who worry about the trade deficit
at the state department are they going
to promote people who don't trust the EU
or the
CCP and at the Pentagon are they going
to promote anyone who opposes having a
woke
military of course not to any of those
questions we know that in every one of
those agencies you cannot reach the
highest levels of the bureaucracy unless
you buy into the woke establishment
agenda and what that means is obvious if
the American people vote for like the
Run of run of a mill president the
weasels burrowed into the bureaucracy
won't cause him or her of too much
trouble but if the American people vote
against the establishment candidate then
the bureaucrats will fight the president
every step of the way now time it again
again the media told us how Brave the
the souls and the bureaucracy how
bravely they fought president Trump
remember Alexander
vinman and once again the allies of the
permanent bureaucracy are trying to
frighten you saying if Trump wins the
world as we know it will end you think
this is a vote about whether or not we
still have democracy in this country it
certainly is you know and and Donald
Trump has told us exactly what he will
do he will not abide by the rulings of
the cour reports uh he uh will certainly
appoint people to office whether or not
they can be confirmed by the Senate oh
oh really she's worried about that well
I didn't hear Liz kick up any dust when
the GAO ruled that the Biden
administration had allowed five
appointees to serve unlawfully three of
whom were still in their positions as of
last February by the way the post all
needed Senate
confirmation and then even though Trump
left office office per the constitution
on January 20th
2021 the Trump derangement sufferers
have to Leap Frog to
2029 do you believe if Donald Trump were
elected next year that he would try to
stay in office Beyond a second term that
he would never leave office there's no
question you think he would try to stay
in power forever absolutely forever and
ever and ever what a silly woman you
notice how she never makes a positive
case for anyone else or makes any
substantive arguments against Trump's
economy or his views on foreign policy
or argue for spending cuts does she ever
do that or does she ever has she ever
taken on the
bureaucracy well this is because Liz and
the 13 Republicans or so who think like
her actually like the appearance of a
democratic process one where the
government remains a system where the
voters get to choose certain officials
but where the permanent bureaucracy
carries out the ERS of the democratic
party no matter which party has the
White House we know what their idea of a
perfect representative democracy looks
like the doj works to every channel to
put the President's chief opponent in
jail the doj flag's parents who protest
at school board meetings and devout
Catholics as well the dod purges staff
who aren't on board with the woke agenda
and of course the ATF they try to turn
lawful gun owners into criminals they
censor people with bogus misinformation
labels and so on and so on liberals and
the completely deranged Never trumpers
Love This setup and they don't want
someone like Trump to expose the scam
they're so funny they try to scare
voters by warning if Trump wins there'd
be Mass
resignations a lot of people who would
um gum up uh efforts by Trump and and
Trump's people to uh subvert democracy
will just simply quit in disgust or
horror or whatever you want to call it
from places like the justice department
and and and so on oh bureaucrats would
quit oh that's a big
loss here's the bottom line democracy
should mean a system in which the voters
have power in our country these days
it's a system whereby the government can
be used against the people so president
Trump is right that system has to be
changed and the the Press squeals about
this plan to take power from the
bureaucrats and give it back to the
voters and the officials they choose the
more you can be confident that he's
right and they're wrong and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else